mover bienvenue pour ce nouvel épisode
de probablement aujourd'hui j'accueille
marie longer cofondatrice de masai qui
propose des solutions pour lentilles
danse artificielle et sur des questions
notamment des tic en silence artificiel
bonjour marie bonjour l'est comment ça
va donc est ce que toi à commencer par
un peu présenter ton parcours
ouais alors j'ai un parcours un peu un
peu atypique
j'ai commencé par une école d'ingénieur
en agronomie avec une spécialisation en
informatique et en fait à cette époque
là c'était le tout début du web 2.0 et
qui me fascinait donc j'ai eu une
dérogation pour faire mon stage de fin
d'études en agence web où j'ai adoré
j'ai adoré les projets sur lesquels
j'étais donc je souhaitais je fais un
stage en d'ingénieurs concepteurs
développeurs et rapidement j'ai été
embauché en tant que chef de projet
technique donc à travailler sur
différents projets voilà pour le web
e-commerce cnra je suis ensuite parti à
genève ont travaillé pour le groupe
richemont qui gros groupe de luxe est en
fait en travaillant avec les différentes
marques du groupe je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait un fossé entre les
équipes digital marketing et le service
informatique
on se comprenait par en fait et donc du
coup j'ai décidé à ce moment là de
reprendre mes études et de faire un
executive master en marketing et
communication de façon à mieux
comprendre le business et à mieux
proposer des solutions techniques qui
répondent mieux à leurs besoins et
ça a été ça a été super super utile et
suite à ça on m'a offert l'opportunité
de passer sur gérer des programmes pour
tout le groupe
donc un programme d'e mail marketing et
un programme de web analytics donc
l'objectif c'était de de définir des
temples est des outils groupe est
déployée dans toutes les marques et à
l'international et c'est là où j'ai
commencé à mettre les mains dans la data
et où j'ai trouvé ça passionnant donc
ensuite bon comme comme je te l'aï déjà
dit j'en avais un petit peu marre de
genève donc je suis retourné à paris où
là j'ai été directrice de projet dans le
service informatique chez lvmh
d'abord pour guerlain puis pour dior et
puis balade à plat ça me manquait quand
même j'aimerais ça quand même super
intéressant on entend de plus en plus
parler s'est passé beaucoup de choses
sur l'intelligence artificielle et c'est
donc j'ai décidé de reprendre mes études
une nouvelle fois c'était c'est assez
récent c'était il ya dix ans donc j'ai
fait un executive master en statistiques
et big data dauphine ou là en gros
c'était c'était c'était une formation de
data scientist et en parallèle chez lvmh
j'ai monté un pôles un pôle data et et
en fait quand j'ai monté ce pôle data
j'ai fait face à pas mal de difficultés
et j'ai cherché des entreprises pour
pour m'accompagner et j'ai vu qu'en fait
il n'en existait pas et c'est de là
dedans vous est venue l'idée de la
massaye ok alors vu jusqu'au les
quelques petites faims donc disais que
lorsqu'il a fait ses études à c'était un
peu sur des aspects plus marketing
[Musique]
tu as dit que c'était très utile ce qui
est des ponts en particulier qui était
très bien en fait côté
côté informatique c'est vrai qu'on voit
le on voit le les projets sous l'aspect
sous l'aspect du code on voit on
comprend l'aspect visuel qui doit être
important mais en fait on comprend pas
les ressorts marketing qui a derrière en
fait les objectifs c'est à dire qu'en
fait quand on fait un site e-commerce
l'objectif c'est quand même de vendre
s'est transformée et donc quand on fait
quand on fait une page web
en fait les le nom des boutons
l'emplacement tout ça s'est pas fait au
hasard en fait c
c'est réfléchi et il ya un objectif
derrière pareil quand on doit s'inscrire
à une newsletter en fait il ya un
objectif de récolter des prospects pour
avoir une base crm pour pouvoir ensuite
s'adresser à ses clients et toutes ces
choses là même si ça peut paraître
évident comme ça en fait je veux je veux
toucher pas suffisamment du doigt je le
comprenais pas suffisamment bien et en
fait d'avoir fait ces études là ça m'a
permis pour tous construisez un projet
ensemble avec les équipes marketing de
vraiment comprendre
quelles étaient leurs objectifs business
et donc de pouvoir apporter des
solutions techniques qui répondait
vraiment a plutôt qu'une réponse voilà
bah si on peut faire comme ça on peut
faire comme ça une réponse que vous
pourrez me paraître logique à moi juste
personnellement mais qui en fait n'est
pas ne répond pas à une logique business
tu penses qu'elle soit ont des
déficiences comme ça chez elles sont
plus qu'en fait les cons sont c'est
vraiment difficile de se comprendre
parce que le métier de l'informatique et
le métier de marketing sont vraiment
très différents et des profils de
personnes qui sont vraiment très
différent
c'est à dire que à l'informatique on va
avoir souvent des personnes qui sont
très rigoureuses très très carré on dit
qu'on fait quelque chose donc on fait
exactement comme ça ils vont suivre à la
lettre les instructions qui ont été
données il n'y a pas de place
pas trop de place à l'improvisation
alors que côté marketing cds profil
beaucoup plus créatif et donc du coup
c'est dépourvu des profils de personnes
qui voient là qui ne se comprennent pas
forcément et côté marketing ce qui va
leur semble et un évident d'un point de
vue business ne l'est pas pour un point
développeurs et ce dont a besoin un
développeur donc de décrire précisément
que quand on clique sur tel bouton save
assure-t-elle pages il se passe tel truc
et toutes les règles de gestion au fait
qu'il ya derrière
pour quelqu'un qui a du marketing il
pense pas que c'est important en fait de
définir tout ça parce que sinon
développeurs il va développer quelque
chose qui est qui à côté de la plaque
donc il ya vraiment un gars vraiment un
gap entre les deux qui est pas toujours
facile à combler ok et donc la deuxième
formation internet c'était plus c'était
c'est plus mathématique en fait donc
c'est une formation une formation de
data s'annonce donc très orienté matt
est un peu un peu informatique et donc
on a vu tous les tous les modèles
statistiques qui sont qui sont utilisés
pour pour pour modéliser des données et
du coup tu fais pas depuis cette
formation eh bien j'ai monté j'ai monté
ma bataille avec avec deux associés donc
l'objectif de
l'objectif amasser en fait c'est
vraiment parti de ce constat là que d'un
côté on a des entreprises qui veulent
aller sur l'intelligence artificielle
sur la data science l ont bien compris
que il y avait quelque chose à faire et
que c'était probablement différenciant
d'un point de vue business mais c'est un
sujet qui est très nouveau donc l ont
pas le pas les compétences en interne
elles ne comprennent pas forcément très
bien quels sont les différents ressorts
les différents écueils la complexité qui
peut y avoir derrière ni vraiment ce
qu'on peut en faire en fait réellement
donc elles font appel à des cabinets de
conseil qui sont de data sayan ce donc
qui ont des datas scientist des datas
engineer des personnes très techniques
qui sont très compétents techniquement
mais qui ne connaissent pas le business
et donc du coup on se retrouve à un
point
un écueil parce que les entreprises ne
savent pas exprimer leurs besoins
parce qu'elles comprennent mal en fait
ce qu'elle pourrait faire avec ces
nouveaux outils
et puis de l'autre côté les datacenters
en général sont très juniors ils sortent
d'écoles ou alors ils sentent le monde
plutôt académique de la recherche et
donc ils ne comprennent pas les besoins
business donc essayer de faire émerger
un besoin et y répondre c'est assez
compliqué donc en général ce qui se
passe en tout cas ce que j'ai beaucoup
constater aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
commence par mettre en place des dates
alec des des endroits voilà on dépose la
donne et on l'a on met tout à
disposition et une fois que c'est fait
bon c'est pas trop quelle est la suite
parce que en fait on ne sait pas trop
quoi en faire et donc du coup l'idée
damas ça c'est pas de proposer de la
data sayan donc on n'a pas d'attaché à
une piste chez nous on a plutôt des des
profils que gartner appellerait des
citizen data scientist c'est à dire des
personnes qui sont tus connaissent le
business est quoi un vernis data sayan
c'est-à-dire qu'ils comprennent pas ce
que c'est que de la science et de la
défense artificiel ce que ça veut dire
que de collecter de la donne et qui doit
être de qualité
ce que ça veut dire que de stocker a
donné un bon endroit de la m accessible
aux datasite east la modélisation les
écueils auxquels il faut faire attention
et puis de d'accompagner du coup les
entreprises dans leurs projets dans leur
projet data ya donc ça commence de
former les s'ils veulent pour leur faire
leur faire comprendre tous les enjeux
qu'il ya autour de l'ia de la tat séance
et puis les impacts potentiels qui
assurent leurs employés parce qu'en fait
il faut pour former les employés puis ça
peut avoir des conséquences
organisationnel aussi ça peut être aussi
faire des ateliers d'idéation pour
essayer de trouver justement des youth
qu'est ce qui pourrait être intéressant
à mettre en place
ça peut être ensuite 2
les aider à rédiger un cahier des
charges a fait un appel d'offres
sélectionner un prestataire peut être
qu'il ya une start up qui propose clés
en mains un outil qui répond aux besoins
nous on va aller regarder sous le capot
pour vérifier que ce que propose la
start-up c'est solide et puis c'est pas
du vent parce que parfois un peu et
comme ça les accompagner jusqu'au bout
et puis les aider à rentrer dans un
processus d'industrialisation en fait de
ces de ces projets là et du coup on a
développé
une méthode de gestion de projet qui est
vraiment adapté à la date assaillants ce
parce qu'on pense que les méthodes de
gestion de projets actuels classique
pour gérer des sites web ou des produits
informatiques classiques ne conviennent
pas la datation parce qu'il ya deux il
ya quand même un gros point
différenciant c'est que on peut avoir
des billets qui s'invite en fait à tous
les étapes d'un projet de data sayan
soul d'intelligence artificielle
à partir du moment où on collecte la
donne est donc le processus de
recrutement de deux grecs de
correctement de la donne et de collecte
de la donner par ou peut-être guézé la
donne et qu'on récolte peut être réglé
la question qu'on pose peut-être mal
formulée et peut-être guézé la façon
dont le data scientist va codé son
modèle il peut y ait amené lui ses
propres billets et donc ça biaise le
modèle la façon dont ils représentent
graphiquement donc l'affairé de la façon
dont les chiffres seront présentés dont
dont tous n'ont les graphiques
ils peuvent être ils peuvent être design
et d'une façon qui biaise
d'interprétation et puis le rapport
qu'il en fait celui qui le lit peut
l'interpréter de façon biaisée
on a des billes à différents niveaux des
billets qui sont sociétaux comme les
vieilles sexiste raciste
on peut avoir de base en rien donné mais
peut y avoir aussi des biais cognitifs
qui sont liées à la façon dont on
interprète à façon dont on comprend les
données donc en fait nous notre objectif
c'est vraiment mettre en place un
processus rigoureux pour s'assurer que
toutes les étapes d'un projet de data
sayan soit bien cadrer la question soit
bien posé que les données soient de
bonne qualité bien collecté que le
rapport qui est fait à la fin soit formé
de façon à ce que il n'y ait pas deux
interprétations possibles et
et que du coup la réponse qu'on est à la
fin parce qu'une bonne réponse à une
bonne question est pas une mauvaise
réponse à une autre question
ouais donc c'est ça
donc il ya un an public ou sur les gays
collecte analyse d'interprétation des
données
quand comment est-ce que ces questions
est ce que tu t'es rapidement posé ses
problèmes
en fait je m'intéresse beaucoup aux
sciences cognitives
je m'intéresse beaucoup aussi à la
sociologie à la psychologie et j'aime
beaucoup faire des ponts entre les
matières est en fait de par mes
différentes lectures je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait enfin des vieilles y
en a partout
bon maintenant est pétri fin tu en as
déjà tombés déjà parlé dans certaines de
tes vidéos est en fait l'adaptation ne
s'est pas une science exacte il faut un
peu sentir les données il faut les
travailler folle et et on a vite fait de
les présenter d'une façon qui leur font
dire un peu n'importe quoi donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui demande
beaucoup de rigueur et et puis par
ailleurs on entend de plus en plus
parler des problèmes d'éthique dans la
data sayan c'est dans l'intelligence
artificielle mais notamment cathie
o'neal qui a écrit un superbe bouquet à
ce sujet qui s'appelle algorithmes la
bombe à retardement où elle explique
bien en fait comment les algorithmes
creuse un accroissement des inégalités
est écrit décret de vrais problèmes en
fait si on ne fait pas attention
justement aux billets qu'il ya dans les
données notamment et bien sexistes
racistes etc
et que ça peut créer de larges problèmes
éthiques
donc effectivement tout ce qui est
éthique c'est quelque chose c'est une
valeur forte pour nous chercher un masaï
on pense que on pense que c'est vraiment
important de faire attention à ça et de
alors on a une juriste dans l'équipe
donc une de mes associés juriste est
certifié hier gpd par la cnil
donc elles nous aident à faire en sorte
que les projets soient break de six by
design c'est à dire qu'on conçoit les
projets dès le début de façon à ce qu'il
soit complète avec la rgpp
on va un cran plus loin en faisant de
l'éthique by design c'est à dire qu'on
s'assure que dès le début les projets
soient soit éthique parce que voilà on
est con est convaincu que c'est c'est
hyper important de faire attention à
salles dès le début plutôt que de
rattraper le coup
après est-ce qu'un projet de r gpd pour
pour les pins pour les gays ne tienne
jouer alors je sais que côté n'y a pas
deux il ya pas de pas de l'air gpd pour
les biens mais au niveau de la
commission européenne ici ils ont ils se
sont rendus compte qu'ils avaient qui
avaient des régulations à mettre en
place au niveau d'intelligence
artificielle et que hergé [ __ ] ne
suffisait pas ils ont publié un ensemble
de recommandations notamment les
algorithmes fasse preuve de transparence
c'est-à-dire que si une décision a été
prise par un algorithme qu'on puisse
savoir pourquoi en fait quelles sont les
raisons ci un crédit m'a été refusé par
exemple on puisse m'expliquer pourquoi
ce crédit même a été refusé sur quels
critères et pas qu'ils aient une boîte
noire où on dise bah non c'est comme ça
c'est c'la c'est l'algorithme qui a
décidé donc ils ont émis tout une sorte
toute une liste de recommandations et je
pense que c'est une première étape qui
vont aller plus loin justement pour
s'assurer que les algorithmes les côtés
data series mc intelligence artificielle
que que les entreprises fassent preuve
d'éthique et fasse attention à ce
qu'elles font avec les données
personnelles
est ce que tu penses aussi au delà c'est
un petit peu au niveau de la bataille
mais ce que je pense aussi au niveau des
entreprises
alors non aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les entreprises avec
lesquelles on travaille honnêtement
l'éthique le côté éthique qu'on propose
c'est un peu la cerise sur le gâteau
mais mais s'en fiche un peu
c'est pas un sujet c'est pas un sujet
qui les importe déjà rgp déjà très
compliqué ça serait compliqué pour elle
parce que ça demande beaucoup de travail
de refonte de
de toutes leurs de tout leur système
d'information tel qu'il avait été mis en
place et puis de tracer les données et
et donc du coup les tic pour le moment
elle n'y voit pas vraiment n'y voit pas
vraiment d'intérêt nous côté à des masaï
ont fait vraiment un pari sur l'avenir
c'est qu'on pense que ça va vraiment
devenir un sujet on l'a vu avec
cambridge analytica et facebook
l'action de facebook a chuté quand quand
il ya eu le scandale là je pense que
malheureusement il risque d'y avoir ce
genre de scandale en france bientôt
aussi et que les entreprises n'auront
pas le choix que de faire attention à
l'éthique
donc nous on se positionne sur ce sujet
dès aujourd'hui d'une part parce que ça
fait partie de nos valeurs et qu'on
pense que c'est important mais aussi
parce qu'on pense que c'est l'avenir
bon c'est quand même pas défini car j'ai
fait des pour ceux qui connaissent pas
mais non car j'ai pdc la sela
regret réglementation générale pour la
protection des données donc c'est c'est
la commission européenne qui a mis ça en
place et qui a émis un ensemble de
règles de façon à ce que les entreprises
soient un peu plus sont un peu plus
sérieuses sur la gestion des données
personnelles des utilisateurs notamment
chaque utilisateur peut demander à ce
que l'entreprise supprime ces données ou
avoir accès aux données savoir ce que
l'entreprise a comme données à sa
disposition
on peut aussi
l'entreprise a le devoir de déclarer
tous les traitements qu'elle fait sur
les données personnelles est la leur gpd
recommande également à ce que les
entreprises ne collecte pas de données
qu'elles n'utilisent pas donc non les
entreprises n'ont pas le droit de
collecter plus que ce qu'elles utilisent
réellement et j'étais je crois pas tu
ranges je crois pas et met alors à leur
décharge c'est vraiment compliqué c'est
vraiment compliqué parce que les données
historiquement chaque département est
assez si l'hôte et dans les grosses
entreprises donc chacune à des données
donc déjà toutes les données ne sont pas
au même endroit puis ensuite les données
sont traitées par différentes d'autres
départements
donc c'est très bien c'est très
compliqué de le retracer tout le tout le
trajet que font les données et et
s'assurer que voilà les données sont
rangées au bonhomme plein d'endroits
sont son son protégé ce qui est une
notion aussi de sécurité des données des
utilisateurs et
et de s'assurer que si un utilisateur
demande à supprimer les données qu'on
les supprime pas juste à l'endroit
source mais qu'on les supprime dans tous
les endroits où cette donnée a pu être
répliquée dans la société
c'est vraiment compliqué savait pas
juste un manque de compétences très
compliqué et ça paye pas qu aux
entreprises du numérique on s'applique
absolument à tout le monde et donc donc
un gpd impose le la nomination d'un
délégué à la protection des données dans
à chaque dans chaque institution
entreprises mais cette personne en
général et tout seul pour gérer un
nombre de projets hallucinant c'est
compliqué l'autre chose qui est
compliqué c'est que on avait déjà un
business qui se comprenaient mal avec
des équipes techniques et on rajoute par
dessus ça une troisième entité qui est
juridique qui ne connaît pas la
technique qui ne connaît pas
parfaitement bien le business et donc ça
génère d'autres incompréhension surtout
quand on rentre dans de la technique un
peu un peu plus et je pense notamment à
tout ce qui est à 2 tech ou là on a donc
de la réplication de données dans
différents systèmes d des tags
management system qui pose un tag sur
les sites juste pour relayer des
déclenchements de de tags de deux
agences d' agences médias par exemple où
la donne et qui circulent dans tous les
sens et à travers différentes différents
différentes start-up différents
différents outils et alors là c'est
vraiment compliqué déjà pour quelqu'un
qui travaille dans l'informatique c'est
assez compliqué alors pour des juristes
pour des gens du business c'est vraiment
compliqué de s'y retrouver et de
comprendre ce qui se passe avec la
donner ouais carrément très compliqué du
coup sur tous ces sujets comment est ce
que tu t'es informe alors je lis
beaucoup jeu
je lis beaucoup d'articles d'articles
sur sur internet
j'utilise beaucoup twitter pour pour
pour m'informer et je lis beaucoup
d'essais comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
aussi bien des essais qui sont vraiment
sur l'intelligence artificielle mais qui
sont aussi sur la psychologie la
sociologie de la philosophie parce qu'en
fait je pense que quand on parle
d'intelligence artificielle saml
tellement de concepts et de sujets que
en fait on peut pas le prendre juste par
le bout technique on passe à côté de
trop de choses parce qu'il ya vraiment
des implications sociétales
il ya des implications psychologiques
parce qu on interagit avec la machine
la machine qui n'est plus qu'un simple
ordinateur mais qui prend des décisions
elles aussi donc qu'on peut pas
s'empêcher de voir comme un individu
alors que cela n'est pas donc
voilà ça pose vraiment beaucoup de
questions et donc voilà j'aime j'aime
bien un peu élargir mes horizons et
nourrir un peu mes réflexions de deux
par différentes matières ça je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ça c'est que autant
il ya l'aspect technique mathématique et
tout ça mais l'implémentation en
pratique déjà ça pose toutes sortes de
il ya besoin de toutes les compétences
de l'impression pour pour pouvoir faire
en sorte que ça se passe aussi
est-ce que tu es revenir un peu dans le
passé et parler un mois du passé que ce
soit repensé étude a parfois c'est ce
que des messages que tu aimerais je
pense que le premier message que
j'aimerais envoyer ses ne fait pas une
prépa bio est une école d'ingénieurs
agro mais fait une prépa maths et une
école d'informatique ça je pense que
c'est mon principal regret parce que
j'adore les majors l'informatique et est
aujourd'hui bon jeu je sais qu des jeux
voilà avec mais les études que j'ai
repris et j'ai repris un petit peu
niveau en maths mais quand même je me
sens je me sens limité ça me plaît
beaucoup et voilà je regrette un peu de
pain il faut pourquoi tu avais choisi
alors tu vas te marrer
j'avais 18 ans j'étais plein d'utopie et
je voulais sauver la nature
[Musique]
j'hésitais jennifer entre l'informatique
et sauver la nature et je me suis dit je
m'étais dit à l'époque que sauver la
nature c'était plus c'était plus classe
tu vois voilà j'avais 18 ans du coup la
cie privée par la troupe peinture qu'est
ce que tu dis à sauver la nature
c'est bien beau mais avec informatique
aussi tu dois aider à sauver la nature
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je pense effectivement que
tout passe par l'informatique
et que si on ne maîtrise pas ces outils
là je pense qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser
le futur je pense qu'effectivement queue
leu leu le changement climatique tout ce
qui se passe c'est tout ça ça passe par
par part d'informations part et par irma
lh2 de mobilisation aussi qui permettent
aujourd'hui très content très content
très concrètement on a beaucoup de
bâtiments par exemple qui se
construisent et qui utilise la data
centers pour optimiser les besoins en
énergie on parle aussi de smart cities
la smart city ça utilise directement la
date assayas et l'intelligence
artificielle que pouvoir ajuster au
mieux les dépenses en énergie et
s'assurer qu'on soit durable et donc je
pense effectivement qu'aujourd'hui un
des moyens les plus efficaces de sauver
la nature c'est cesser de faire des
maths c'est très contrainte et il fallut
beaucoup des constats mais c'est pas
très très connoté jeu mais si on
réfléchit un petit peu qu'elles sont un
peu les priorités des groupes
écologistes aujourd'hui et ça passe
souvent beaucoup par de l'information
qu'elle soit que ce soit même la
sensibilisation mettre à disposition des
informations fiables sur lequel est
invaincu organiser toutes les
informations savoir quelle est la
meilleure action envers de entreprennent
pour le lait le pineau soit si au fond
il faut des données font au fond
d'informations gérer tout ça et même
dans la façon d'être de transférer cette
information que tu communiques quelle
est ta stratégie de communication sur
facebook sur youtube qui tu vas toucher
mon tout ça c'est du marketing digital
en fait donc si tu maîtrises pas ces
outils là tu peux pas toucher peut pas
toucher les bonnes personnes ouais donc
tard ce mois ci à l'informatique c'est
pour sauver la nature
je passe ici si tu avais dis merci a
vous êtes plusieurs années 3 on est
trois donc il ya une sophie qui est qui
et donc juristes et qui est un
certificat en fdp des et il y à audrey
qui est ingénieur généraliste et qui a
fait beaucoup d'entrepreneuriat
dans des grosses entreprises et
d'innovation donc elle amène la
casquette innovation design thinking est
donc en fait à toutes les trois donc moi
comme j'ai raconté j'ai un profil assez
assez transverses un peu business un peu
technique data science et ses atouts t3
en fait on a vraiment la volonté de
faire en sorte que nos consultants ils
ont leur transmettent en fait nos
connaissances et qu'ils aient tous un
vernis dataslide un vernis gestion de
projet un vernis design thinking
l'innovation et un vernis rgp des de
façon à ce que quels que soient les
sujets sur lesquels sur lesquels ils
travaillent ils puissent avoir les
réflexes de penser bastien est ce que ce
qu'on est en train de faire là c'est
vraiment concret de terre gpd tient là
cette entreprise elle a des données qui
sont intéressantes mais visiblement elle
arrive pas à faire émerger des idées
différenciante
peut-être que on peut faire un atelier
pour pouvoir un atelier de design
thinking pour pouvoir faire émerger de
nouvelles idées
voilà l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir des
consultants un peu couteau suisse
vous avez à recruter des consultants
vous vous envoyer dans se disant très
exactement exactement et du couloir fait
une formation
on attend les former en continu on
essaye de faire tous les mois
un de passer deux heures sur un sujet
sur un sujet particulier donc on les
femmes quand ils arrivent chez nous et
ensuite tous les mois on essaye de faire
avec avec tout le monde
des petits des petits rappels
parler de voile à de nouveaux sujets
soient des niçois des rappels sont des
nouveaux sujets parce que par exemple
sur la réglementation il peut y avoir
des choses qui qui bouge
soit des nouvelles techniques de gestion
de projet ou ou autres les alimentent
continuellement pour qu'il soit vraiment
top
au top de ce que de ce qu'ils peuvent
enfin de ce que nous un masaï on peut
apporter aux entreprises
2 ça fait un an qu'on est en phase de
croissance et c'est ça ça se passe bien
bah ça se passe bien on en vient il ya
un vrai marché en fait parce que
beaucoup d'entreprises valse m elle se
mettre à la data lié à cuba comme je
disais tout à l'heure ils n'ont pas les
compétences en interne
donc il ya dû y aller vous un vrai
besoin il ya un vrai besoin
j'ai du mal à trouver des clients qui
n'ont besoin d'eux aujourd'hui ce qui
est plus compliqué c'est le recrutement
hockey parce qu'en fait on cherche des
personnes qui ont une appétence business
c'est à dire qui voilà qui comprennent
vraiment le ballet métier quoi que ce
soit que ce soit du marketing où on peut
travailler aussi sur des sur des sujets
de ce plat et chen bin voila c'est
vraiment avoir la fibre comprendre
le besoin concret du client et puis du
fibre datamat c'est donc c'est des
profils vraiment assez particulier et
qui sont assez difficiles à trouver
donc c'est là où c est ce qu il yad
autres
en fait je crois pas aujourd'hui nos
concurrents c'est plutôt les les
entreprises qui font la datation hans
donc qui ont des datacenters des dates
ingénieurs etc et qui ont des
consultants également pour travailler
avec eux
donc ces consultants la font concurrence
avec nos consultants mai
déjà nous ce qu'on propose c'est un
package avec hergé [ __ ] l'éthique
l'innovation des infiniti et c'est donc
ce que ne proposent pas les autres et
l'autre point qui est important pour
nous c'est que en fait la raison pour
laquelle on ne veut pas avoir de date à
scientist c'est qu'on ne veut pas être
juge et partie donc on veut être
agnostique de technologie et on veut
être considéré comme tiers de confiance
par par les entreprises et donc se
situer vraiment entre l'entreprise et
son prestataire technique
donc là on est on est vraiment le seul à
être sur ce créneau vraiment spécifique
d'accord ok et parce que les gens du
milieu donne une importance politique
que vous avez est ce que tu commençais
reçues par les entreprises ils s'en
foutent un petit peu ou est ce que c'est
bah ça comme une contrainte quasiment en
fait aujourd'hui c'est pas un sujet ok
c'est juste pas un sujet pour eux rg pdc
déjà
c'est déjà compliqué ça leur demande
déjà beaucoup de ressources donc donc
l'éthique c'est pas un sujet c'est
vraiment voilà un plus un plus pour eux
qu'on apporte mais qu'est ce qui vous a
fait qu'est ce qui pourrait être fait
pour qu'on l'emporté en politique alors
ce que je crois c'est que on va avoir la
data serian c'est l'ia 20 s'inviter dans
tous les départements des entreprises
bon je pense que on va les entreprises
pourront pas faire l'économie de ça ça
va ça va 100 ça passe ça va s'insérer
partout parce que ça va permettre à tous
les niveaux aussi bien sûr chez les rh
de ce qu ils tiennent le marketing la
prod
les usines l'intelligence artificielle
va permettre d'optimiser un peu tout et
donc je pense que tous les tous les
collaborateurs des entreprises devront
être formés à l'ia et la datation pas
d'un point de vue technique mathématique
mais juste d'un point de vu comment ça
fonctionne
quel est l'état d'esprit derrière que la
machine elle ne fournit qu'une
recommandation qui est statistiques et
pas une vérité absolue
donc il faut garder un esprit critique
et donc je pense que toutes ces
personnes là doivent être doivent être
formés et et que c'est par elle que peut
passer justement l'éthique parce que
c'est elle qui vont être au contact
direct des machines et des
recommandations pour enfin que vont
donner les machines et c'est elle qui
vont pouvoir se rendre compte que
maintient le résultat là il me semble il
ne semble pas juste il me semble qu'un
truc qui un truc qui va pas par exemple
c'est amazon qui avait développé un
outil un outil pour aider les rh donc
l'outil l'outil lui donner 1000 cv en
entrée et puis il parcourait les cv elia
disait faut recruter ces cinq-là est en
fait les rh se sont rendu compte au bout
d'un moment que pour les profils pour
les profils de développeurs ou très
technique l'ia ne recommandaient jamais
de femme
donc ils sont posé la question ils ont
cherché et en fait ils se sont rendus
compte que comme ils ont entraîné la
machine sur les cv du passé de ces vingt
dernières années et des cv d'autres
entreprises et que bas historiquement il
ya plus d'hommes que de femmes à des
postes
technique la machine en a déduit que
c'était des postes pour les hommes et
donc à écarter les femmes alors même que
dans les cv les cv n'était pas genre et
c'est à dire que le genre n'apparaissait
pas mais la machine
l'heureux le reconnaissait qu quand même
à travers d'autres d'autres petites
formations
et donc là c'est scélérat qui peuvent se
rendre compte de ça que leurs
recommandations elle est biaisé et qui
est un problème derrière donc je pense
que ce sont vraiment toutes ces
personnes à tous les collaborateurs qui
ne viennent pas de l'informatique qui ne
viennent pas date assayas et qui vont
être obligés travailler avec ces
machines c'est eux qui vont avoir la
responsabilité de voile à se rendre
compte de ça et de faire remonter
l'information à l'heure à leur
management
gano c'est comme ça qu'on forme les les
personnes conforme dans l'eau dans les
entreprises on leur explique comment
fonctionne l'ia et on leur on leur
explique vraiment que la décision leur
revient à eux et jamais à la machine
c'est pas la machine-outil dessine c'est
eux qui doivent qui doivent décider qui
leur en as décision et qui donc doivent
regarder les résultats de la machine
avec avec un esprit vraiment critique
est ce que je pense qu'il ya parfois en
même temps est ce qui est des situations
de plus 100 km et un conflit entre
éthique et rentabilité
alors on pourrait croire que oui mais je
suis persuadé du contraire parce que
d'une part je pense que une entreprise
qui n'investit pas sur l'éthique llc
face à de gros risques en fait parce que
s'il ya le moindre scandale qui éclate
c'est fini pour elle quand j'en viens je
reviens facebook et cambridge analytica
ou facebook
l'action a chuté suite à cette suite à
cette annonce
exactement voilà donc
donc je pense que je pense que c'est un
c'est ça va être indispensable
d'investir sur sur l'éthique et à côté
de ça en fait il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ont râlé contraire gpd
parce que c'est engager beaucoup de
coups chez eux pour mettre en place les
recommandations qui ont été faites mais
en fait je pense que il faut le voir
comme une opportunité
c'est à dire que le fait de mettre en
place hergé pdc une opportunité de kiné
ses data de l'état était en silo c'est
l'opportunité de les mettre dans un data
lait qui est de la mettre tout à
disposition et de pouvoir donc du coup
fin d'année soldats stationnés derrière
c'est et l'éthique je pense que c'est
pareil en fait c'est que pour que
l'entreprise soit éthiques
il faut une une méthode
deux projets qu'ils soient rigoureuses
celle dont je parlais tout à l'heure
donc nous on s'est inspiré en fait de ce
que google appelle la décision'
intelligence et qu'ils ont mis en place
c'est tout une méthode de projet pour
s'assurer que en fait la donner et de
qualité elle est bien rangé
la question qu'on pose et la bonne
question le modèle qui est fait derrière
et le bon modèle le dta scientist s'est
bien posé la question de quel est le
score pour mesurer le modèle de bien
choisir le bon parce que en fonction de
bon alors je vais parler un peu
technique mais ça va être les les
mesures de acura si precision recall ou
f1 donc est-ce qu'on prédit plus de faux
positifs ou de faux négatifs
c'est donc ça peut tout changer en fait
donc cesser des questions qu'il faut se
poser est donc je pense que mettre une
méthode rigoureuse en place ça ça
garantit que ça garantit pas mais ça
accroît les le fait d'être le plus
éthique possible et en plus de ça
d'avoir des résultats qui sont qu'ils
sont les meilleurs
les meilleures possibles donc en fait je
pense que c'est plutôt du gagnant
gagnant en fait au plus on y rigoureux
et au plus on est à la fois éthique et
on a des bons résultats qui tienne la
route et qui sont maintenant à bhl et
c'est un peu lorsque comme dans son
devant d'un programmeur de nettoyer son
code écrit documentation son pote ça à
faire chier à fond sur le moment mais
voilà sur le long terme ça peut être
exact ou de développer des tests des
tests unitaires c'est pareil ça emmerde
le développeur mais ça permet de gagner
un temps fou derrien est-ce que vous
avez des débats éthiques récurrents
entre vous en dira sans âme à sa
personne des conflits au sein de
l'éthique alors il ya des kids et des
questions éthiques
il y en a 10 ans n'at il y en a plein
je pense que la plus célèbre est celle
qui revient tout le temps
c'est cette fameuse ce fameux dilemme du
tramway avec les voitures autonomes
donc la voiture autonome
il se passe quelque chose soit
l'écrasent
une personne âgée soit elle écrase un
enfant quel choix elle doit faire et là
dessus évidemment personne n'est
d'accord il ya le m haïti qui avait fait
une test à ce sujet et ils se sont rendu
compte en fait que d'un pays à l'autre
il n'y avait pas les mêmes résultats
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas la même
morale d'un pays à l'autre et est en
fait cette question là elle n'a pas de
réponse parce que soit on a une morale
plutôt déontologiques et puis qui va
donner la réponse tout de suite soit on
avoir une morale plutôt
conséquentialiste donc on va essayer de
réfléchir aux conséquences de l'écraser
plus tôt l'un écrasé plus le jones qui
est ce qui paraît horrible dit comme ça
mais bon et après il y en a d'autres qui
disent eh bien dans la vraie vie c'est
le hasard qui dessine donc laissons le
hasard aussi décider et donc il faudrait
programmer la machine pour lancer une
pièce et et finalement ne pas choisir
mes skis et paraissent qui paraît
contre-intuitif aussi donc ça c'est le
sujet sur lequel personne n'est d'accord
et mekki mais qui en fait ma plus loin
en face au delà des voitures autonomes
c'est à dire que quand on va voir un
robot humanoïde en face de nous et qui
nous casse le bras
la responsabilité elle est où parce que
c'est pas un individu pensants mais
c'est enfin voilà quelle est la
responsabilité qu'est ce qu'il agira de
faire pas faire ça ça pose vraiment là
il ya tout un ensemble de questions pour
lesquelles il ya vraiment y'a vraiment
pas de réponse et une personne n'est
d'accord
et après il ya un ensemble de questions
éthiques qui se pose où là il ya plutôt
ya plutôt consensus sur le fait qu'il ya
un problème éthique
mais il n'y a pas forcément les réponses
typiquement il ya le cloud actes donc le
cloud acte c'est le fait que les
entreprises américaines peuvent donner
les avale des informations dont elle
dispose sont utilisateurs si le
gouvernement leur demande donc c'est à
dire que toile est par exemple trump
pourrait demander à voir toutes les
données qui est que google et facebook
assure-toi exactement du moment que
c'est une entreprise américaine et donc
imaginons la russie se met à faire un
1 le même même genre de même genre de
choses c'est à dire que toutes ces
personnes qui se sont amusés avec faith
ap la russie pourrait récupérer tous
leurs visages toutes leurs photos qui
sont pris tout leur sel fille et puis
éventuellement les reconnaître avec des
caméras de reconnaissance faciale
on peut tout imaginer quoi et ça pour le
coup c'est assez inquiétant et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas vraiment de
réponse sur comment est ce qu'on
pourrait faire attention à ça est ce
qu'en fait ce qui est terrible c'est que
nos données personnelles ne nous
appartiennent pas en fait on allie ya
des entreprises qui font de l'argent
avec nos données personnelles mais ne
nous appartiennent plus en fait dès lors
les lors qu'on les a dès lors qu'on les
a partagées et je trouve que je trouve
qu est ce qui me trouve qu'il manque le
fait tu vois avec le berger [ __ ] on a
maintenant sur tous les sites les
petites peaux peuple qu'ils disent est
ce que je veux bien être traqués ou pas
mais je trouve que ce qui manque ce
serait la possibilité de dire je veux
bien que traquer mais par contre
uniquement à tlf un telle forme de sel
fin et et pas telle autre tu voit
typiquement je vais bien et il est je
viens de craquer pour avoir de la
publicité ciblée
mais je veux pas être que mes données
soient utilisés
par des politiques par exemple tu vois
je trouve ce manque de contrôle qu'on
assure sur nos données c'est vraiment
problématique
je ne sais pas je sais pas mais je
trouve que je trouve que c'est en fait
je trouve pas ça gênante partager nos
données avec les entreprises parce que
ça nous apporte des services en train on
en est tous super contents de bénéficier
ce qui est le plus gênant c'est de ne
plus avoir la main et la maîtrise de ce
qui est fait de nos données et j'ai peur
que ça j'ai en fait j'ai du mal à la
pression que ses fils car du coup comme
moi j'écoutais un podcast jours de m
flashforward qui paraît des images
satellites
aujourd'hui avec les images satellites
la nsa ou autre est capable de nous voir
à peu près ce qui se passe mais bon ils
voient pas les individus un à un ils
sont pas guéris de sa reconnaissance
faciale sur un individu
mais voilà probablement dans cinq ans du
coup bas façon qu'elle va rassurer et
magique
je suis ton pessimiste mais c'est vrai
que en plus aux états unis
et puis duel maison mais le gouvernement
a l'air d'avoir vraiment la mainmise sur
soi sur beaucoup de données qui
transitent et après même le gouvernement
chinois et à a édicté des
recommandations éthique sur
l'intelligence artificielle
donc bon si tout le monde se met à
émettre des recommandations éthique on
peut peut-être espérer que ça aille dans
ce sens je pense qu'il ya des trucs qui
vous critiquent ces choses qui vont
prendre de plus en plus d'importance et
parce qu'en plus on a des solutions et
puis ça paraît pas trop coûteuses sont
des imprimantes et voir façon bénéfique
par contre sur la presse aussi je suis
moins est-ce que tu as d'autres grandes
préoccupations éthiques vis-à-vis de
l'utilisation des données les antilles
en sortir ma plus grande préoccupation
c'est les inégalités sociales parce que
alors il ya le il ya effectivement les
billets raciste sexiste mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est assez visible et
que c'est
c'est vraiment des sujets qui me choque
l'opinion et qui vont être et qui vont
être traitée assez rapidement en
revanche je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'algorithmes qui effectivement creuse
les inégalités sociales et ça j'en
reviens ou aucun de cathy o'neal
algorithmes la bombe à retardement elle
en parle très bien et elle montre très
bien comment en fait c'est un cercle
vicieux et les algorithmes
en fait il cible une cible les
catégories de population les plus
faibles pour les rendre encore plus
faibles et les plus riches encore plus
riches et ça ne fait qu'accroître en
fait la distance la distance entre les
deux et ça ça me tient c'est quelque
chose qui m'inquiète au sable et un
autre point aussi qui m'inquiète et je
sais que c'est inquiète aussi
c'est tout ce qu'ils les bulles
informationnel où effectivement sur
trois avec avec twitter avec facebook
avec youtube on se retrouve coincés dans
des bulles d'information qui qui nous
intéresse alors pour nous c'est hyper
c'est hyper confortable c'est hyper
intéressant parce que plutôt que d'être
noyés sous d'information on reçoit
vraiment l'information qui nous
intéresse mais ça ne fait que nous
conforter dans nos opinions
donc là le biais de confirmation il agit
et c'est là où et ça renforce je pense
la montée de l'obscurantisme qu'on peut
voir avec les platines aux états unis
avec tous et ensemble de croyances et de
plus en plus de défiance en plus envers
la science envers les médias
et ça ça me fait ça ça me fait vraiment
peur parce que je pense que c'est comme
ça que montrent que montrent les
extrémismes les actes en fait et quand
on voit en fait justement comment claude
léger analytica a permis le break site a
permis à train de monter au pouvoir en
utilisant en fait en faisant de la
propagande mais en utilisant de façon de
façon super cibler la balle il des
publicités sur sur facebook ben je me
dis que si si les les partis extrêmes se
mettent tous à utiliser ce genre de
technique là c'est vrai c'est inquiétant
je souhaite a mis le documentaire alors
oui son déclencheur je me suis fait une
réflexion avoir conduit aussi je suis
une réflexion c'est que je trouvais que
le narrateur insistez beaucoup sur le
point des données privées alors que
panda beau documentaire montre un punk
qui est plus inquiétant encore c'est la
manipulation politique à très grande
échelle
c'est très préoccupant en plus les
plateformes aujourd'hui sont conçus de
telle sorte que mes seins et des
mouvements extrêmes sont beaucoup plus
virulent hervé et le truc qui m'a
interpellé aussi c'est que il focalise
tous sur cambridge analytica qu'il
décrit comme le diable voilà
mais en fait comme reggiani atika et se
fasse du tout laisse pas faire ça du
tout ce n'est pas du tout les seuls
donc ça donne l'impression que voilà le
diable opérer maintenant il est terminée
ils ont déposé le bilan donc tout est
fini mais non en fait non c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus large et de rides
en fait aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
faire de la pub virale sur sur facebook
sur google
c'est un an c'est également normal me
suis cassé l'impression qu'on a de plus
en plus de la colère mal dirigé lustre
aux couleurs comptera quelque chose
focalise toutes les attentions avec
surtout si on arrive à identifier une
personne partiellement responsables ont
défini comme le grand coupable du coup
cambridge à l'éthique château mais en
fait le premier eut beaucoup plus
fondamentale et donc ça sera un autre
truc qui m'inquiète c'est la baisse de
capacité d'attention
j'ai l'impression qu'on des recherches
qu'ils qui suggère sa queue et un autre
vote cas ce que j'ai écouté hier donc
c'est très récent champion dans un
podcast de your hands up high yield
tention qui parlait d'une hutte chercher
ce qu'appelle gloria marque qui étudiait
le temps qu'il nous faut poursuit chez
d'une tasse d'une page à une autre pour
des gens qui craquent dans une
entreprise réfléchir et a estimé c'est à
40 secondes suite eu toutes les 40
secondes on a pris l'habitude de 40
secondes et moi ce qui me fait peur
c'est que voix sur sur des sujets on
reprend le 6 on a quarante secondes pour
identifier un coupable
c'est convivial et on passe à autre
chose serait alors qu'il prenne soin ont
nécessité plus de temps de réflexion
du coup à ce que tu as des idées pour
combattre ses grands problèmes
alors j'ai lu récemment un truc super un
article super intéressant
alors c'est un alors je me souviens
malheureusement pas du nom du nom du
gars mais en fait ce gala il a
il était alité ils étaient désespérés
ils étaient en grande dépression
il a sauté d'un pont et il se trouve que
il est pas mort en fait il en est
ressorti
et ensuite donc il a mis des années à se
remettre un peu tout ça et c'est donc
c'était je crois que c'était il ya une
quinzaine d'années que ça s'est passé et
il se posait la question de et si et si
on m'avait tendu la main et si quelqu'un
m'avait dit quelque chose et si sur
internet j'étais tombé sur des réponse à
ma question est donc du coup ils ont
utilisé il a utilisé adwords pour sur
des mots comme dépression suicide
comment suicider il a donc
guide est sûre c'est sur ces mots là de
façon à ce qu'ils aient des annonces
pour se faire aider qui apparaissent
quand on quand on cherche quand on
cherche ça et ensuite il a suivi
derrière
les clips qui ont été faits dessus et eu
pas mal de clips qui ont été fait même
de coups de fil qui ont été passés à ces
centres qui aide les gens qui sont en
grosse dépression et donc son poinçon
son truc c'était de dire ben laden
on s'en sert pour pour les entreprises
pour vendre pour de la propagande
on peut aussi s'en servir en fait pour
faire des choses bien et aider des gens
juste en achetant sur des mots en fait
que personne n'achète donc il coûte pas
grand chose et est donc de promouvoir
des trucs qui peuvent aider les gens en
fait échouer ce intéressant comme comme
approche
c'est vraiment génial vraiment
intéressant aujourd'hui je suis entendu
juste comme ça j'ai pas pu vérifier mais
apparemment facebook a fait une étude
sur est ce que en scrollant
l'utilisation de facebook augmentent à
la dépression une certaine catégorie de
personnes est apparemment facebook a
conclu que oui l'utilisation de
notamment du scroll sur facebook parce
qu'ils se croyaient beaucoup sur
facebook c'est quand même un signe aux
risques des dépressions donc oui seront
du coup on dirait qu'ils favorisent est
un peu la dépression et en plus que
était possible d'intervenir s'il ya une
personne scroll beaucoup va peut-être
qu'on va lui mettre ce qu elle dit des
messages en fait qu'ils sont faits qui
qui augmente la praille était que la
personne doit continuer à se creuser et
du coup à passer plus de temps sur
facebook donc c'est bien pour facebook
mais en fait en scrollant encore plus
les prénoms par un peu plus et du coup
oui il ya moyen non seulement de
diagnostiquer la dépression avec
l'utilisateur en fonction de
l'utilisation de cette plateforme mais
peut-être aussi on étudie d'intervenir
et de proposer donc ça peut être en
achetant directement dans les publicités
c'est un peu bizarre décidément
publicité met sa patte aussi dit ça doit
devenir carrément de ces entreprises
c'est s'il y avait un peu plus de
pression sont responsabilisés davantage
d'entreprises en disant qu'ils ont une
conséquence sur la santé des gens et une
capacité de traitement aussi
d'accompagnement ou je pense que c'est
vraiment de l'éthique très grande
échelle
d'accord et pour l'instant facebook
c'est effectivement pas trop au point
sur le sujet parce que j'ai un ami qui
est alcoolique il ne voit sur facebook
que des publicités pour des trucs qui
ont trait à l'alcool et ça le rend fou
elle rend fou et là il ya un vrai
problème éthique tu vois c'est ça la
pole toi c'est très gros problématique
parce que là c'est un exemple
certainement parmi des c
là je pense que raconter genre
d'histoire que peut aider et encourager
ses entreprises
franchement il faut plus de pression de
public tu as sur ces entreprises j'ai
interviewé celle d'avant normalement qui
est un ancien employé de youtube et qui
parlait de ça et ce qu'ils disaient
c'est que lui quand il possède youtube
google 2010 et 2013
lui il a essayé de mettre en avant ses
problèmes éthiques
elles sont à 100 de google peut-être
qu'il s'est pas créé de la meilleure
manière disait que peut-être qu'ils
allaient prince tessa de façon trop
théorique voiture est il que c'est pas
passé parce qu'il disait c'est que
apparemment maintenance a un peu changé
quoi à cause notamment de prendre tout
cas
petit à petit il ya une petite pression
un peu plus pour les titres qui vient à
la fois choisi l'extérieur et de
l'intérieur et six contre quatre
mondiaux restant un petit peu analyse
autocritique de ce que les défauts ce
que vous pensez que fait que tu penses
que un masaï pense-t-on fait peut-être
pas assez bien que pourrait mieux faire
j'ai des trucs que vous faites
particulièrement bien déjà berlin donc
forcément on est une entreprise qui qui
débute donc c'est sûr que
c'est pas on ne fait pas tout bien on a
vraiment une volonté de de s'améliorer
avec nos avec nos employés donc on
favorise on essaie de favoriser au
maximum le retour d'expérience les
changes
le fait que de favoriser en veut aussi
l'émergence d'idées parce qu'en fait
c'est pas toujours facile dans les
entreprises de pouvoir proposer des
idées voilà et émettre son avis et faire
changer les choses mais nous c'est ce
qu'on essaye de me sèye de valoriser en
fait parce qu'on pense que tout le monde
a quelque chose d'intéressant à apporter
donc on favorise enfin brice beaucoup ça
la créativité est aujourd'hui ben
j'étais parler de la méthode là qu'on
est en train de mettre en place donc
elle n'est pas elle n'est pas encore
parfaite donc il faut encore qu'on faut
encore qu'on travaille dessus pour
pouvoir voire l'améliorer
comme je disais elle est inspirée de la
décision telegent chez google mais
google n'a pas sorti beaucoup
d'informations sûres sur ce sujet là
donc je pense que s'ils partageaient un
peu plus sur le sujet ça pourrait nous
aussi nous enrichir pour pouvoir aller
un peu plus loin dans nos réflexions
parce que c'est vrai que pour le défi
c'est de mettre en place une méthode qui
permettre qu'ils permettent des projets
menés de façon rigoureuse sans que ce
soit trop lourd et trop compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre et qui soit aussi
suffisamment agiles donc c'est assez
compliqué de trouver le bon degré de
d'agilité et de rigueur pour pour mener
les projets la meilleure façon possible
parce que parfois tu sens des tensions
entre ce que tu te sens obligé de faire
et ce que tu voudrais en faire
ben ça va peut-être t'étonner mais non
c'est génial or c'est ben en fait je ne
supporte pas la dissonance cognitive
ça me je ne supporte pas d'être centre
dans cette situation là donc en général
quand tu fasses à deux choses et que
j'hésite entre deux choses et que je
suis tiraillé entre deux choses je vais
me poser je vais laisser dresser la
liste des pour des contre pondérer tout
ça et je vais prendre une décision et je
m'y tiens et j'ai pas revenir en arrière
[Musique]
mais tu as parfois pas non plus des fois
où tu te dis par exemple pour faire
grossir à massa
ces parts étaient obligés de faire un
truc mais c'est pas la façon il est à le
promouvoir l'éthique mais parfois des
délices heures de tension comme ça
bajeux n'ont jusqu'à présent j'ai pas de
super c'est que c'est un super projet
c'est que la ccc rend intéressant
d'essayer de trouver ce genre de trucs
tout est bien aligné quoi sur entre ce
qu'on souhaite c'est que avec mes deux
associés on est vraiment toutes les
trois alignés surtout sur la son autre
façon de voir les choses de penser sur
les valeurs sûres notre façon de
travailler
donc c'est hyper fluide et c'est enfin
csu c'est super agréable à regarder mais
venez super motivant ce que je mène
qu'il ya pas un ouais j'ai pas mangé des
amis de travail la recherche en sécurité
de lille hoc et il ya livrant des
questions qu'ils pensent vraiment
important qui est facile mais qui sont
difficiles et sur lequel il y avait très
peu de chances d'être publié il mène
d'avoir des résultats
mais ça c'est important on sent que ces
trucs qu'il faudrait quand même faire
des résultats partiels mais voilà quand
on est dans le nom de recherche - mais
cette pression pour publier oui mais
comme dans une entreprise nous on a la
pression de gagner d'argent pour de
payer nos employés donc forcément voilà
mais je pense qu'il faut savoir aussi
rester pragmatique et trouver le bon le
bon équilibre tu vois mais du coup ça
s'est un peu paris également on arrive à
trouver le bon équilibre mais parfois y
est pas obligé de jongler obligé de
publier
du coup on fait des compromis mon sens
beaucoup c'est un peu frustrant parce
qu'on vous dit peut-être que si
financement la recherche était différent
aussi les 5e et 6e en dehors de nous tu
vois ses pantalons main
il ya peut-être moins de réfléchir un
petit peu plus donc c'est un peu parce
que ce qu'on fait des groupes comme koné
n'ont pas envie de mettre dans la course
à la publication du coup on peut sortir
de truquer demandé d'argent en défilant
trente milliardaires - pour qu'ils ont
eue cet argent était tout marché
mais peut-être qu'on peut essayer de
repenser certaines façons de faire dans
la recherche
oui probablement de toute façon il ya un
je pense qu'il ya un gros problème en
france déjà il ya ya ya très peu de pont
entre entre la recherche et les
entreprises
et ça je trouve que c'est vraiment je
trouve ça vraiment dommage en fait parce
que en fait les deux mondes peuvent
devraient pouvoir s'alimenter
donnez la recherche pour avoir un peu
plus d'argent les entreprises pourraient
vraiment bénéficié de la recherche et
j'avais jamais vu qu aux etats unis je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose de l'ordre
de 70 à 80% des sociétés qui sont qui
sont en lien avec avec avec des
laboratoires de recherche et des start
up
alors que ce chiffre qui tombe à 30 % je
prends en france donc
je sais que le gouvernement français
essaye de mettre un petit peu de
dynamique dans tout ça pour pour faire
en sorte que ces trois pôles donc les
entreprises de start up les labos de
recherche travaille un peu plus ensemble
mais on est encore loin on encore loin
du compte et ça c'est quelque chose
aussi sur lequel on aimerait travailler
avec la massaye c'est qu'on aimerait
s'approcher justement des laboratoires
de recherche et d'essayer de voilà de
faire en sorte que certaines de leurs
recherches puissent être utiles au monde
au monde de l'entreprise
ouais du coup quand tu vois le
développement de différents scénarios si
ça se passe bien ça se passe très bien
ainsi notre objectif c'est de grossir et
d'être à 50 personnes dans cinq ans
voilà et d'avoir du coup ben de
continuer de pouvoir aujourd'hui on fête
aujourd'hui on axe surtout sur la partie
accompagnement projet on aimerait
pouvoir développer plus la partie
justement rgp des juridiques éthiques
donc on aimerait vraiment un pouvoir
grossir cette partie là donc aujourd'hui
on passe par la petite porte et puis on
se dissémine les informations sur
l'éthique on essaie de faire passer les
bonnes la bonne parole sur ces sujets là
mais on espère que d'ici quelques années
ce soit vraiment un sujet d'importance
et qu'on puisse faire des vrais projets
intéressants sur le sujet
oui j'ai une question aussi qu'il va
avoir une fin du mois est ce qu'on veut
travailler avec la cnil est ce que vous
avez des eaux comment se situe à knin
parce que j'avais un avis sur et parce
que c'est vrai pour le plus important
alors je pense que ma collègue anne
sophie pourrait répondre plus
précisément à cette question parce que
celle la juriste commission nationale
informatique et libertés et
moi je peins je pense que oui il devrait
avoir effectivement un peu plus
d'importance alors c'est délicat comme
question parce que s'il avait déjà que
les entreprises ont un peu une dent
contre la cnil c'est un peu compliqué
mais je pense qu'il devrait plus
s'exprimer en fait je pense qu'il
devrait faire plus d'information et de
pédagogie
ouais ouais je pense je pense parce
qu'aujourd'hui la réglementation la
telle qu'elle a été mise en place
ben ça en fait ça nous embête moi aussi
en tant qu'utilisateur parce qu'on se
retrouve avec des pop up en fait surtout
des sur tous les sites et en fait
machinalement on clique sur qui tous sur
ok machinalement sans réfléchir
oui oui oui mais je vous sais ça et du
coup toi et moi pourtant on sait ce que
ça veut dire et alors des fois je prends
le temps des fois je prends le temps et
je coche je passais trucs mais je le
fais ouais une fois sur dix et la
plupart des gens en fait ne comprennent
pas vraiment les ressorts de tout ça en
fait en fait c'est marrant parce qu'il
ya deux catégories de personnes les
personnes qui s'en foutent qui disent
que c'est pas leur problème et puis
voilà
et puis les personnes qui sont
complètement slip et qui pensent
qu'elles sont traqués qu'elles sont
qu'elles sont fliqués que on sait tout
sur elle que et qui fit vraiment
complètement sur le sujet alors que la
vérité elle est plutôt les plus tôt
entre les deux en fait et je trouve que
c'est dommage que justement la cnil est
décidé et impose aux sociétés de balle à
mettre ses pop up pour gérer les cookies
mais sans vraiment
expliquer et vulgariser parce que ça
signifie derrière on fait que qu'est ce
qu'elles en font les entreprises de ces
données emplois ce n'est pas que
maléfique c'est aussi utile en fait
c'est un service que ça nous rend à nous
en tant que consommateur et ça je pense
que les gens s'en rendent pas forcément
compte non plus
et donc je trouve que ouais la cnil
pourrait faire un peu plus de
communication
je pense que c'est vraiment sur ça c'est
l'impression que avoir exigé des sites
web qui m cette bannière a globalement
j'ai du mal à dire que c'est vraiment
positif pas voir ça donne une mauvaise
image de vraiment passé un éthique de
lire des données a pour moi comment
exactement a besoin un peu plus de
réflexion sur des actions qui sont qui
sont plus efficaces et chansons engagées
mais c'est un poème vraiment je pense
que je pense que c'est un vin
d'empreintes difficile à expliquer tout
ça oui la lésion aux parents des
grands-mères de comprendre pourquoi en
ce qu'elle appelle recommandations c'est
compliqué mais mais je pense que c'est
indispensable parce que comme je te
disais tout à l'heure je pense que l'ia
va s'inviter dans partout elle l'est
déjà parfaite partout dans notre
quotidien sont personnes s'en rendre
compte les gens on dira j'ai peur de
pillages et père de liam en fait il y
avait déjà dans nos téléphones
elle est déjà sur nos ordinateurs elle
est déjà partout et je pense que tout le
monde va être amené à travailler avec
des outils basés sur l'ia donc je pense
que c'est indispensable en fait que les
gens et des notions de comment ça marche
et que c'est juste en fait des super
calculateurs qui font juste des stats et
pas plus
du coup petite idée pour la cnil
peut-être investir
[Musique]
est ce que tu vois d'autres problèmes
importants pour aujourd'hui pour le
futur bas des problèmes importants
ouais j'en vois j'en vois deux mois qui
2 3 qui m'inquiète le tout ce qui est un
changement climatique
on sait déjà ce comme je te disais tout
à l'heure je vais sauver la nature je
suis sensible à ce sujet là et est en
fait je suis hyper pessimiste sur ce qui
se passe et et ça ça m'inquiète vraiment
parce que j'ai l'impression que on en
parle on en parle quand même pas mal
dans les médias mais il n'y a pas de
prise de conscience quand on en parle
avec les gens et une
déresponsabilisation sur sur le sujet
alors peut-être qu'ils comprennent
prêtre qui veulent pas voir peut-être
qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils comprennent pas
bien ce que ça signifie et je sais pas
mais ouais mon impression c'est que
cours des six dernières mois la dernière
année on va dire six derniers mois il ya
eu une haute et de des discussions de
discussion oui mais quand je parle de
plastique par exemple avec les gens les
gens ne comprennent pas le problème qui
avec le plastique et je suis effaré de
voir tous ces plastiques
quand on va le midi quand je vais manger
dans voilà les petits les petits restos
qu'il ya à paris tu sais pour les pour
les employés chaque fois c'est bien
d'être plastique et la quantité de
facile qui est générée est monumentale
et chez soi chaque fois qu'on achète un
truc et du plastique c'est
c'est en fait à partir du moment où on y
fait attention on se rend compte que la
quantité de plastique qu'on jette
elle est délirante alors c'est pas
recyclables et en fait les gens ne
voient pas le problème à chaque fois
j'en parle avec des gens qui disent
maintenant on trouvera une solution oui
mais si mais si recyclés ou n'est ce pas
grâce est stocké dans des cheminées
charge bah ouais mais en fait ça se
retrouve beaucoup dans la mer et est ce
à de sérieuses à de sérieux problèmes
alors c'est peut-être c'est vrai que le
réchauffement climatique ça en tête
encore plus un problème encore plus
important mais même là dessus j'ai pas
l'impression que les gens se rendent
compte que à leur échelle en fait
ils sont maison une responsabilité et
c'est à notre bouger des choses beaucoup
plus moi je suis là par axa comme mais
c'est ça c'est vraiment être un autre
prêt et je trouve que c'est un autre
produit lancé c'est un son de diffusion
des responsabilités et y compris sur les
questions éthiques au sein des
entreprises s'est passé c'est impossible
pour un programmeur de se sentir
responsable du code qui fait saliver
toute une chaîne et c'est aussi très
réussi pour un manager de se ressentir
la santé et au sein d'entreprises une
diffusion de responsabilité et puis
après entre les entreprises opposées
entre elles sont diction vous avez aimé
parce que les consommateurs disent c'est
la responsabilité des entreprises mais
entreprises elles elles répondent aux
demandes des consommateurs chez les
consommateurs c'est une diffusion de
responsabilité et puis le gouvernement
bat c'est ce qu'attend de leurs
électeurs donc en fait
c'est je pense qu'il n'y a que les
citoyens qui peuvent faire qui peuvent
briser cette ce cercle ce cercle vicieux
mais pour ça est-ce qu'il faut plus
d'informations est ce qu'il faut mieux
informer
est-ce qu'il faut être peut-être moins
catastrophistes et parce que j'ai
l'impression que le fait d'être
catastrophiste ça bloque
ça bloque les gens peut-être qu'ils
écoutent moins bien les messages enfin
je sais je sais pas c'est difficile
voilà une autre préoccupation kg par
rapport à ça c'est la qualité de
l'information
oui c'est un con ce derby on a fait
fondre climatique c'est important après
vont promouvoir une idée qui en fait est
potentiellement même contre-productive
des villes fantomatiques absolument qui
est là après voilà il ya toute la
diffusion tout la diffusion des chèques
newsday la propagande d'al et le manque
de le manque de recul que peuvent avoir
effectivement parfois les gens sur ce
qu'ils lisent ce qu'ils entendent ça
aussi ça me touche ça très préoccupant
en fait parce que parce qu'en fait il
suffit qu'ils aient un un groupe un
groupe un peu extrêmes qu'ils sachent
manipulés qu'ils sachent se servir de
tous ces outils là et avec des bons
moyens de communication qui maîtrise
bien tout ce qui est publicité en ligne
qui me plaisent bien
je me dis mais les dégâts que ça peut
faire son fils ben ouais bon on les
observe d'écouter parler de problème
mais en fait c'était ça le deuxième ok
bon bah je fais je précisais d'autres
choses que tu voudrais rajouter alors je
suis en train de lire un livre super que
je recommande que je recommande beaucoup
aux auditeurs c'est system un système de
daniel kahneman je sais pas si tu vas tu
réduis et
et alors si en plus c'est bien écrit
c'est facile à lire ce que parfois idées
et celles qui sont un peu qu'ils sont un
peu ardu celui là est vraiment facile à
dire et il est vraiment très éclairant
sur en fait tous les biens auxquels on
est soumis au quotidien en permanence et
je trouve c'est hyper important parce
qu'en fait quand on est dans une
discussion avec quelqu'un d'autre
on se dit oui il a forcément tort et
c'est en fait je pense que je trouve que
de savoir ses propres billets ça permet
aussi de se dire attends est-ce que moi
même je suis pas en train de me de me
fourvoyer par mes propres par les
propres biens est également c'est ce que
je disais aussi plutôt dans l'interview
c'est dans mon métier dans l'adaptation
c'est dans l'ia je pense que c'est hyper
important de faire gaffe
assez assez biais là parce qu'en fait on
entend souvent on peut faire dire ce
qu'on veut aux chiffres
mais en fait c'est vrai si on tord le
truc on peut effectivement faire dire
n'importe quoi donc je pense que c'est
hyper important de ce d'essayer de
mettre ces biais de côté et d'être le
plus rigoureux possible pour que les
chiffres disent la vérité et parce qu'on
veut leur faire lien c'est tellement un
point important mais beaucoup de gens
qui parlent des problèmes des
technologies nouvelles et j'ai presque
on me dira que enfin c'est pas un si
gros problème parce qu'on peut largement
des et nos portes qui avec des réunions
sont des statistiques des statistiques
pourrait qu'on l'ait choisie on étire
épique comme ça et puis d'ailleurs les
médias c'est vrai que avec les photos
qui choisissent avec les mots qu'ils
utilisent parfois c'est vrai que c'est
un peu
ça
tu vois avec les titres publics
voilà c'est typiquement il joue sur il
joue sur les biens pour voir pour nous
attirer sachant que c'est dommage qu'ils
rentrent dans ce qu'ils rentrent dans ce
jeu là je trouve ça dommage de donner
trop d'importance ne sont de fait que
nous parce que une fois que vous venez
vraie prime c'est ce qu'on puisse des
billets que cas où tu as même si on
résolvait les n'ai fait que nous mais
ils restent très déprimées ça c'est
énorme c'est sûr c'est sûr bah merci
beaucoup à un mari pour lui même et pour
les auditeurs vous dis à bientôt
probablement